[Music]
Nimrod by Elgar music to remember one of
his friends as we remember and prepare
for the national act of remembrance
/ sells music when I am laid in earth
echoing the countless funerals that took
place in the field at battles and after
battles
our soldiers take care of their own and
it is those countless memories be they
buried in the land or in the foaming
seas of the world we will remember them
[Music]
as service men and women of today watch
the cross bearer of the chapel's royal
leads out the 10 children of the
chapel's royal in the six gentlemen in
ordinary the director of music the
sergeant at the best rate jonathan
simpson the forces chaplain the
venerable john ellis chaplain in chief
of the Royal Air Force the sub Dean of
the chapel's Royal Lieutenant Colonel
the Reverend cannon Paul Wright and for
the first time the new dean of the
chapel's royal the Bishop of London the
right reverend and right honourable Dame
Sarah Mullaly
a reminder that so many battles
throughout the history of the British
Armed Forces there has always been time
to stop time to reflect upon religious
elements in preparation for battle and
those religious elements have in their
own way played a valuable and quiet part
in the preparation of each service man
and woman for the challenges of Buffalo
away from their mothers and fathers
their families
amongst their own and gathered in the
sense of duty religion has always played
its part in private words our servicemen
and women in battle
[Music]
led by the Prime Minister
the leaders of our political world take
that place to honor the dead
[Music]
followed by previous prime ministers who
have also liked the present Prime
Minister taken the responsibility for
sending Britain's armed forces into
battle around the world other
representatives of
the House of Lords and house of commons
different political parties the leader
of Her Majesty the Queen's opposition
and behind them and to form a square
around this
center of the world thought and the
nation's active remembers
representatives the Civil Services the
ambassador of Ireland the chief of the
Defence Staff and the Chiefs of the
Naval Army and Air Staff
joining them with
wreaths of poppies from thoughts around
what was once the British Empire
the Commonwealth
the personal message from the Prime
Minister written upon her wreath ready
to be laid as so many of Prime
Minister's have since Lloyd George was
the first to lay his wreath in 1920 at
the base of the temporary zametov which
became such a permanent symbol and today
we remember a hundred years ago and we
remember so many other military
activities and combats that have led to
the loss of sons and daughters and
members of families
representatives of the wide
representation of religious belief - are
here this year for the first time
representatives of the humanists
recognition that parts of the population
have many different ways of finding an
understanding of this universe in which
we take our lives and face our
challenges and the Queen's skypes either
side of the entrance waiting now to play
their part in salute to the Queen's
wreath and other wreaths and members of
the royal family can you come out and
take their position
shortly her Majesty the Queen will take
her position on this central balcony
above the main entrance this great
Cenotaph with its empty tomb is ready
for your thoughts wherever you are when
you join us here for this national act
of remembrance echoed in villages and
times all over the kingdom and
throughout the empire
Her Majesty the Queen will now lead the
nation in remembrance as we remember a
hundred years ago the armistice that
ended the Great War
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you're watching Sky News and the
national act of remembrance as Her
Majesty the Queen's aquarii brings
forward the sovereigns wreath for the
Prince of Wales to lay on behalf of Her
Majesty
on behalf of the queen he salutes
and in that wreath the nation the
Commonwealth are led in remembrance for
the first time at the invitation of Her
Majesty the Queen on the advice of her
government president of Germany ladies
room
the hope of peace in the world so
heavily upon those shoulders in
remembrance of two world wars a respect
shown from a nation of allies in 2018
His Royal Highness the Duke of
Edinburgh's wreath is laid on his behalf
His Majesty the Royal Highness was at
the moment when the Imperial Japanese
forces ended their conflict as a young
naval officer he watched
the Prince of Wales's wreath with its
three feathers of the heir-apparent
field-marshal the Prince of Wales
salutes
and the first group of numbers of the
royal family led by the Duke of
Cambridge with the Duke of Sussex the
Duke of York who served in the Falklands
War and wearing uniform of the
territorial army as it was and had the
army reserve the Earl of Wessex later
reads the other Wessex has found the
names of the lost service lost their
lives and placed it upon his card in
remembrance of the terriers who served
in the first world war the second group
led by the Princess Royal with the Duke
of Kent whose father was killed in a
crash in Scotland during the Second
World War
as probably it's Michael Kent who served
like the Duke accountant in the British
Army for many years
another parade which has stood in
attention for the national act of
remembrance will be stood at ease
[Applause]
and standing easy the funeral march in
b-flat minor
by Beethoven
and the Prime Minister on behalf of Her
Majesty's Government will lead the
political leaders in laying her wreath
[Music]
the right honourable Jeremy Corbyn
leader of the Labour Party and leader of
the Opposition mr. Ian Blackford the
Westminster Scottish National Party
leader and on behalf of both the
Scottish national and applied kamut
parliamentary group
[Music]
the leader of the Liberal Democrats the
right honourable Vince Cable
[Music]
the leader of the Democratic Unionist
Party in Westminster the right
honourable Nigel Dodds
[Music]
on behalf of all members of parliament
in the house in homer's the speaker the
right honorable John Burke
[Music]
[Applause]
and on behalf of parliamentarians in the
House of Lords the right honourable the
Lord Fowler Lord speaker
finally with flowers gathered together
to represent the United Kingdom's
overseas territories the Secretary of
State for Foreign and Commonwealth
Affairs the rebel Jeremy
[Music]
amongst asiimov is their different
colors and the places from which they
come bringing a reminder of how far
reach the influences of the United
Kingdom throughout the history that we
now reflect upon in particular as the
nations of the Commonwealth step forward
in the first group the kingdom of Canada
the kingdom of Australia the kingdom of
New Zealand the Republic of South Africa
and the Republic of India for the Queen
and her family the role of leadership
which has been heralded hereditarily
carried particularly from the Queen's
grandfather King George the fifth rule
on this day a hundred years ago would
have reflected upon losses as
representatives of Pakistan Sri Lanka
Ghana Malaysian Nigeria Cyprus Sierra
Leone Tanzania Jamaica Trinidad and
Tobago and Uganda
[Music]
the vast quantity of nations involved in
the first world war becomes so clearly
evident is
like commissioners and their
representatives Kenya Malawi molted
George Cross Zambia The Gambia Singapore
Guyana and Botswana add to the growing
red around this
Portland stone memorial
the representatives of Lesotho Barbados
Mauritius
teeny promise wasn't hunger the Bahamas
Grenada anybody else
[Music]
some of them islands so beautiful so
far-flung so peaceful and yet so brought
into the mayhem and madness of a world
at war not just concluding its fight in
1918 but in the Second World War - and
many conflicts beyond
[Music]
finally the representatives of the
Solomon Islands the Commonwealth of
Dominica st. Lucia Saint Vincent and the
Grenadines Valley's Antigua and Barbuda
Sir Christopher and Nevis Brunei Namibia
Cameroon Mozambique and Rwanda and we
remember Zimbabwe also there's so many
sons of boaters who lost their lives in
two world wars
our closest neighbor and ancient friend
representative ambassador of Ireland
recalling so many from the whole island
of Ireland both the Republic of Ireland
and Northern Ireland who laid down their
lives
[Music]
and while the chief of the Defence Staff
General Senate party watches on behalf
of the three services the chief of the
Naval Staff Beresford owns the chief of
general Martok on the asset our Chief
Marshal Sir Stephen Illya
the civil services are never forgotten
for their role in battle and this year
representatives of the Merchant Navy and
fishing fleets captain David Johnson the
air transport Auxiliary Association mr.
Christopher Garrard and the National
Fire Chiefs Council Y Wilshire and the
service will be led by the Dean of the
chapel's Royal Sarah Mullaly
Oh Almighty God grant we beseech thee
that we who here do honor to the memory
of those who have died in the service of
their country and of the crown may be so
inspired by the spirit of their love and
fortitude but forgetting all selfish and
unworthy motives we may live only to thy
glory and to the service of mankind
through Jesus Christ our Lord amen the
hymn o God our help in ages past our
help for years to come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
teach us good Lord to serve thee as thou
desirest to give and not to count the
cost to fight and not to heed the wounds
to toil and not to seek for rest to
labor and not to ask for any reward save
that of knowing that we do thy will
through Jesus Christ our Lord amen
our Father which art in heaven hallowed
be thy name thy kingdom come Thy will be
done in earth as it is in heaven give us
this day our daily bread and forgive us
our trespasses as we forgive them that
trespass against us and lead us not into
temptation but deliver us from evil
under God's gracious mercy and
protection we commit you the Lord bless
you and keep you the Lord make his face
to shine upon you and be gracious unto
you the Lord lift up the light of his
countenance upon you and give you his
peace this day and always the rose will
be played followed by the national
anthem
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the Queen will bow to the Cenotaph as
the Prince of Wales will salute Prince
Wales will lead the president of Germany
after this historic laying of a wreath
on this 100th anniversary of the
Armistice into the Foreign and
Commonwealth building followed by other
members of the royal family who have
laid their rays on behalf of the nation
and on behalf of a memory of king george
v who first laid his wreath here at the
Cenotaph in 1920 just two years after
the end of hostilities the aquarias
follow and one can only imagine the
weight of responsibility upon a
sovereign Queen as she is of 16 Nations
the first to be informed of any soldier
sailor a man or woman injured or killed
as the Dean of the chapel's world lead
that religious element which has been
serving as the chapel's royal were
intended to King's back to the 14th
century and it was the chapel's royal
who went with King Henry the fifth the
battlefield of Agincourt
and the English army crossed the river
at the Somme unknowing of a great
tragedy and calamity would hit so many
families in that Battle of the Somme in
1916
on the Prime Minister's shoulders now
the responsibility of the deployment of
the United Kingdom's Armed Forces on her
advice they are sent in the Queen's name
with the parliamentarians who must also
lead us with views and a democracy that
has proved so expensive in human life to
maintain former Prime Minister's they're
leaving
and other ministers and representatives
of government
as the Commonwealth leaders leave
represented here by their my
commissioners and representatives it
really is possible to recall how many
nations were once part of the British
Empire that was in a state of utter
relief a hundred years ago right now in
the first half hour of the war to end
all wars also
nations around the world but are such
friends in so many different ways the
Chiefs of the Armed Forces responsible
for preparing training getting soldiers
sailors airmen and women ready for the
challenge of delivering violence against
the Queen's enemies to protect the
democracy we cherish here in the United
Kingdom representatives are so many
religious thoughts attitudes views hopes
bought here to represent
that followers to me
finally the major general commanding
household division salutes to the
senator as he is chief of staff and a DC
leave from this Hollow square the
military salute itself from the living
to the dead of the Senate the empty tomb
the national act of remembrance led by
the Queen is now concluded
but it is only the beginning for today
we will see the March passed shortly of
all those gathered here by the Royal
British Legion was national president
now takes his wreath to lay it on behalf
of
a charity that has done so much for
servicemen and women preparing these
acts of remembrance and organizing this
annual ceremony here at the Cenotaph
our marshal Walker as the national
president leads others who will lay
their roof - including
immortal it's a very north
who represents the Royal Air Force's
Association mr. Charlie brine is
national chairman of the Royal British
Legion Scotland
this is patricia crimes
she's the women's section challenge of
the world british legion women's section
general global Richards who was once
chief of the Defence Staff
whose deputy grande president at the
Royal Commonwealth X Services League mr.
Keith Ridley national chairman at the
Royal Naval Association and mrs. Pauline
cotton representing Transport for London
[Music]
their respective reflowing forward the
reeds
[Music]
the order and structure through which
all ceremony and pageantry has done in
United Kingdom is perhaps a National
League motif but it's also the means to
which former servicemen and women know
how best to honor memory and remember
the dead
[Music]
the tune fame and glory follows the
trumpet voluntary and sultry we will
hear the pipes again with the pea broth
have Donald do
[Music]
under the instruction of major-general
Ben bath has the image general
commandingly Heisler division
corporations are made to ensure that
this prey
mr. poet are done to the finest and the
highest of Britain standards and the
garrison sergeant major mr. Stokes
will have held his rehearsals in
barracks nearby Whitehall where all the
Commonwealth representatives will have
been to make sure that as we have seen
do you honor and respect is done here at
the Cenotaph
there we see the great coffin shape at
the top with its wreath of eternal
memory and into it I hope your memories
from the two-minute silence are placed
the representatives of the Royal British
Legion will now move inside and take
their position on the balconies were
emotive the Queen was joined by the
Duchess of Cornwall and the Duchess of
Cambridge - with
act
and that brick wreath looks down upon
the reorganization of this playground in
order to prepare for the various columns
of the veterans who have quietly been
waiting up towards Trafalgar Square for
their chance to march past this national
symbol of remembrance
[Music]
their memories are legion their medals
are endless and the stories that they
have to tell are an emboldened
encouragement to every generation that
follows who perhaps one day we'll have
to take their place in defending the
freedoms and security of families here
in the United Kingdom the various
different regimental bands at the
household division take their position
at the head of each of the various
columns we will now march past
[Music]
[Music]
there isn't exactly a change of pace
although you will notice that the
marching music is slightly slower for
those who are veterans a slower pace for
a senior age but as each column of
veterans with their memories the
organization's they represent the
different colors that their berries the
badges that are so deeply important to
the fraternities and sororities that
they represent as they pass many carry
their own wreaths these will be
individually taken and placed upon the
Portland stone steps of the United
Cubans principle site of memorial
[Music]
the music is unchanging year by year
prepared by the mass bands at the house
of division many of whom took part in
the Lord Mayor's Show only yesterday and
yet each of these bits of music have a
traditional echo that is important for
the United Kingdom
[Music]
[Music]
tell us the scale of the pike for every
down here actually Senate are in this
late autumn sunshine magnificent scenes
around me and I'm joined by Katherine
Davis Lee I had a remembrance with the
Royal British Legion I just want to get
your thoughts are very good to see if
Katherine you know your feelings about
today what a magnificent see actually
extraordinary and I was just standing
here reflecting much of the conversation
this week has been about how we engage
with youth and the the younger
generations and how important
remembrance is today and standing here
for that two-minute silence with so many
young people and so many people are from
across the generations and knowing that
not only here in London but across the
country that was the case it just felt
like the nation really came together and
it's just been an extraordinary service
of remembrance you've got a front row
seat here there we can look up and down
at the crowds it really is that issue as
the bat strikes up again no really as
you say
which is incredible and we've been
acknowledging that contribution I mean
one of the bonuses of being here is of
course we get this magnificent humour
one of the dad ties about this Megan
honey over the band's but tell me about
copies and sales this year in particular
because of the significance of 2018 so
we created more poppies than ever this
year at 20 million copies with a target
of 50 million for the Poppy Appeal year
final numbers won't be in but certainly
I know that the demand people wearing
poppies has been everywhere that we've
been engaging with thank you where we've
been talking to people about saying
thank you for that first world war
generation for that service and
sacrifice we've just been met with
enthusiasm they're people wanting to
acknowledge it as you can hear hear as
well as see as the veterans tell me
about a little bit about the history of
you know it's its origins we all know
about founders field but when did he
take off be worn by we actually had I
don't have him here now but I was
holding earlier this morning a box of
hoppers before I started the Royal
British Legion which came into being
with the senator in 1921 and Papi's
organic Hebrew as a symbol for peaceful
future see just lay it on the level for
us from the British Legion to so much
debate about size of the ceramic pig
cetera et cetera do you mind
what kind of pot I mean you clear it up
with specific position of the leaf
should you have elation lovely well I
have one on both sides say with pride is
what we say the Armed Forces the service
and sacrifice was for the freedoms that
we have in our world today and everybody
is free to do and they would choose to
do and so we pride is where we are and
do you have pride as you mentioned there
that it has been passed on to the next
generation I have seen far more people
wearing Papi's pant and about on the
streets than than ever before it
certainly feels like that is the case
and that there's been an extraordinary
engagement across the country with both
the centenary and with remembrance and
so yes hopefully that we can carry that
torch on into the thread into the next
century
well are you worried I've never been
worried about that in the you know kind
of hit a high-water mark there's been
four years of coordination with those
years of the Great War now it's it's
over it's a hundred years over but next
year the year after it's got to keep
going it has got to keep going I mean
next year is the 75th anniversary of
d-day
but remembrance and and the March master
is not just for the centenary of the
First World War but for all service and
sacrifice for the Armed Forces across
all complex our forces are out today
still doing amazing things so and we are
there for the six point seven million
Armed Forces and veteran population of
this country six point seven million
just tell us a bit more about how the
money is used where it goes
and what projects so the Royal British
Legion looks after the welfare of the
Armed Forces and the veteran community
and in all sorts of incredible ways but
we are responsible for six care homes
across the country nursing staff that
help with all sorts of problems we have
sixteen pokken centers across the
country and so once you have done a day
service you
connects and the British Legion is there
for you throughout life whatever your
needs and will help you in any way that
they can or put you in touch with the
right service to help you
there are real concerns there about the
point of some of our service personnel
those that have served in various
there are always concerns and we always
strive to do as well as we can but our
doors are always open and we are always
there for people
but some of the specific problems you
know we hear particularly about PTSD we
hear about service personnel ending up
disproportionately in prison we do hear
about these things obviously I am the
head of remembrance so sit with much
more of a remembrance at on in there and
the specifics of acknowledging that
service that we're here for today and we
can we can talk about yes but a
fantastic day all around
a beautiful day thank you very very much
indeed for joining us and with that
let's go back to house to Bruce to talk
us through some of the scenes
well Dermot it's always a special time
when the veterans the people who
remember the fights that they have faced
are marching past but maybe the most
eloquent symbol here at the Cenotaph of
all of them is the widows cross it was
right here
almost immediately after the royal
ceremony its white carnations a very
simple reminder of the utter pain of
widowhood and it represents how families
themselves in that most powerful way
handle loss
[Music]
and each of the organizations marching
past now have their stories to tell but
we have some special new contingents
marching past this year the Scottish war
blinded the Fraser bruh and Macduff
Gordon Highlanders Association the Royal
Welsh comrades Association the Adjutant
General's Corps an amalgamation of many
different organizations that themselves
celebrated the Armistice a hundred years
ago the Royal Artillery Association 41
squadron Association the Royal Air Force
Mobile meteorological unit and the Royal
Air Force Yeates buri Association
welcome to them and many others and the
mobility scooters are in evidence here
reminding us all of some of the
challenges faced by veterans and the
support that's given to them by
countless charities to which many people
contribute greater Minds through hearing
the benefits that the Royal British
Legion gains from those people who put
money into the collectors boxes at
stations and other places up and down
the country even in the newsagent a
small box beside at the daily paper
raises money to help those who have
served the United Kingdom and then
subsequently need a little bit of help
to get by
and all the time watched by the
generation that is represented in the
Royal Hospital at Chelsea the gentlemen
closest to me has as his last medal the
legend honor of France which tells me he
landed on d-day with all those others
and the French are good at always
recalling those Second World War
veterans who played their part in the
liberation of France the Scarlet that
they represent the livery of the kings
of England as the in pensioners who had
a bit of attention books to be looked
after Chelsea they passed let's listen
to the music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the music playing at the moment oh oh oh
what a lovely war which was one of the
many songs that Tommy's that the British
Army sang as they marched back into the
horrors and the boggy nightmare that was
trench life they spent only a few days
on the very front line they spent some
in the rear lines and then they had
periods of leave to deal with some of
the cold and wet that they'd had to face
in that very frontline but very often
that trenches were but a hearing
distance a couple of yards even from the
enemy ready to kill them and that degree
of pressure
surrounded by probably the
lifeless and tragic remains that their
friends who were killed in the last
assault only smell of what would
inevitably be the case particularly on
those long summer French afternoons
dealing with the horrors of war but that
war ended a hundred years ago today and
it is more modern conflicts that we
principally recall as the music played
there by the mass bands at the household
division and particularly you can see
the blue plumes of the Irish Guards
[Music]
so the world war 1 melodies followed by
the songs of the Great War and then the
Brahmans and Royal Air Force bands will
start with they'll always be in England
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today we mark 100 years since the
Armistice and I'm always moved by one
almost shakable fact that fills me with
almost dramatic shock and that is that
at the event in Sarajevo in 1914 when
Archduke Franz Ferdinand was shot which
triggered the process towards the great
conflagration of the First World War the
irony is that the car he was driving had
the number plates or license plate a 1 1
1 1 1 8
Armistice 1111 1800 of course you could
say it but chance but it's a surprising
chance and it's a fascinating car to see
in the museum at Sarajevo and what a
thing to recall 100 years old as we all
do in remembrance
[Music]
the famous blueberry of those who have
served as part of the United Kingdom's
forces in the United Nations work to try
and keep peace the United Nations that
was established after the Second World
War hoping to be more successful than
the League of Nations which was
established after the first world war
but each colored buried the maroon of
the parachute regiment the brown of the
guards division and other infantry
organizations and those who are injured
by war or have become unwell since all
looked after and all kept on this great
March and you know later on all of these
people will be out in the pubs and bars
of London they'll be in their groups
they'll be as they are clapped on here
by those who come to support them and if
you get the chance wherever you are in
the United Kingdom or around the
Commonwealth
see anybody today with their medals on
gern ask what they're about go and ask
the stories and buy them a drink
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we see the corner there
parade goes round into Parliament Square
they actually go back to Horse Guards
Parade where Her Royal Highness the
Princess Royal is taking the concluding
salute and each member of the royal
family takes their turn to represent Her
Majesty the Queen and to make the
veterans know that their presence here
their involvement in this event means so
much from Scotland representatives of
regiments now amalgamated into the Royal
Regiment of Scotland but each individual
identity still represented by those who
have come down from Scotland or who
serve in that regiment in its past and
who live in other parts of the world
gather together and come to lay their
eggs together and meet afterwards they
are all individually cheered and clapped
by those who come to support this parade
[Music]
the Black Watch for instance the Black
Watch in whose ranks Her Majesty Queen
Elizabeth the Queen Mother's family
often served her brother Fergus was
killed at the Battle of Loos in 1915 and
as the wife of King George the sixth she
always held memory of her brother and in
memory trying to keep that Scottish
element clear in memory
[Applause]
[Music]
also this year marching past for the
first time the YMCA the National
Federation of Women's Institute's the
West India regimental Heritage Trust
Polish ex-combatants Association trust
my grandfather worked in the Royal Navy
and received an honor from Poland for
his work integrating the Polish brave
fighters into the Allied fight back
against Hitler and the German invasion
of Poland
[Music]
many of these songs are those that were
sung during the Second World War and
there'll be people at home now who can
remember the words and perhaps will let
them sing out amongst their families as
we listen to the music
[Music]